this is a production of Cornell
University
uh welcome I wish I could you know Carl
we're losing our reputation the last
couple of shows have been going 35 40
minutes so yeah we got to get back to
the 30 minute thing and I'm not sure
it's going to be so easy because there's
so many things uh to chat with Dr
Sorokin about so welcome to the show
um Everybody uh you know we've got a
real treat today one of the leading
international experts him and his former
Mentor uh Trey Rogers uh two of the
leading voices in this particular area
we're talking soccer today and this is
an overhead view of I think John was
this the only permanent Stadium
um actually that's a good question I'm
not sure there's a couple that are
permanent stadiums that they've kept
there's because that one's taken down
made out of shipping crates yes yeah 974
was shipping containers for sure and
that that one's they they're dismantling
but a lot of them they're just reducing
the capacities the seating capacities
for but keeping them permanent and the
thing you can see in this on the right
hand side for those of everybody
watching on news Channel 8 here the heat
pumps I guess there was a few of those
they had to use uh what was the
temperatures like in Qatar at the time
you know actually when the World Cup was
going on it was fortunate their cool
season but it was still you know in the
60s and 70 degrees 80 when it started
they were in the 80s and 90s oh so it
did cool off yeah it did cool off but
it's usually in the 70s and 80s but in
the summertime when my the first time I
went there was it was over 100 degrees
110 degrees or something so well now
we're very excited our uh three
countries coming together uh to host uh
2026 and obviously this is keeping you
busy uh I think I got an accurate map
here of uh the locations and I guess
you're getting to go back to the
Homeland uh a little yeah well that was
the original one actually that's a this
is an old picture that this is the
original bidding cities all the cities
that bid
and you know Edmonton didn't get it
Montreal pulled their bid
um Baltimore DC didn't get it Cincinnati
Nashville Orlando Denver so the ones
okay well we're gonna get to this in a
minute but which uh location in Canada
Toronto and Vancouver okay Vancouver so
the Vancouver has been added yeah okay
great all right so listen let me get
through the weather Carl's got some
really cool stuff to talk about that'll
be a a nice segue into a couple of
things I've gotten then we'll really get
deep into this it was a cool week last
week and a cool start to next week
um we're gonna be 10 to 12 degrees above
normal when it starts to break after
Memorial Day by midweek we should be
routinely uh in the 80s around here next
week and that's really going to kick
start things we've got some new data if
you look at our on our new runoff page
that Carl's created on the forecast
website we've got this nice tracking of
both air temperature and soil
temperature both you know what we have
today and what we're expecting and you
can see that bump into the 80s coming
and soil temperatures getting well into
the mid 60s finally as we get into June
so I would say we really been cooler
than what you would have thought we
would have been based on the way the
season started soil temperatures are
still hovering now in the 50s and you
got to go pretty far south to get into
the mid 60s but really the story is dry
we have become extremely dry
particularly in the middle part of the
region and this past week it was
exceptionally dry virtually no rain a
little bit of rain came along the coast
and if you look at the last month you
can see the real strong gradient from
dry to the west and wet to the east
especially along the coast places that
have been dry in the past now are
starting to get fairly wet so you got
some areas along the coast that are 200
percent of normal in the last month but
the majority of the region is starting
to show pretty widespread drought stress
now on on lawns and if you've got grass
on Sand you can definitely see the
drought stress coming now no rain is
coming we might get a little bit to the
South and a little bit to the far north
but the high pressure conditions are
going to continue to dominate the region
now really one of the biggest things we
worry about with sports field managers
is is weed Invasion and the potential
impact that could have on field safety
and performance and we are just starting
to get into the crabgrass germination
period you know downward John where you
are in Tennessee crabgrass has already
been going and I'm sure Brosnan's got
you know three four five tiller
crabgrass uh on your way down there as
well so crabgrass is just getting going
for us and something to keep in mind
where you have these bare areas on your
field is where you're likely to see uh
some of these plants starting to come in
so Carl let me pass it on to you because
obviously field performance and safety
is going to be a big topic today uh on
the show and I know you've got some
interesting things that we've learned
firsthand from working with our what
would I mean are we lost in the National
semifinals this year the Cornell's men's
soccer team lost the national
semi-finals yeah so we've become uh you
know sort of a national program now
Cornell soccer we've had uh coach Smith
come in a bunch of years ago has really
sort of transformed the program uh we've
been keeping track of nationally ranked
Cornell soccer team we're the only team
to beat the eventual champ Syracuse last
year we beat him early in the year
eventually lost to him uh in the
National semifinals by a goal but uh
this was actually the the regional game
Regional Tournament game that we hosted
uh back in December uh so these these
the NCAA tournament happens uh towards
the end of that fall semester and being
in Upstate New York we are uh it's It's
Not Unusual to have a light dusting of
snow at that time so this was the
morning of that Regional game we're
hosting this game we get very light
dusting of snow light enough to actually
blow the the field off so I went over
the in the morning started checking it
out uh was was kicking the ball around
with the soccer coaches and sort of
getting there
uh their opinions on how the field was
playing and it was interesting to see uh
and hear from them what they were
interested in so one of the first things
when they see the snow it's cold it's
it's below 30 degrees they're sort of
looking at the bounce of the ball so
they don't want sort of a too too high
of a bounce on a lot of the synthetic
Fields I'm sure you you hear John
there's these big bounces and yeah and
uh this is a picture I pulled from from
John's Twitter account you guys are now
sort of measuring the rebound of the of
the the soccer ball uh that's maybe
different from some of the other
firmness measurements uh we they have
the firmness tools we have at our
disposal may be measuring different
things so they care about the bounce and
then they cared about sort of how the
ball reacted after that first bounce so
these lobbed through balls if if you're
a fan of you know the Premier League or
other leagues where counter-attacking
teams they sort of sit in their
defensive shell once they get the ball
they got one or two guys who are going
and they're trying to lob it over uh the
defense but they want some check on that
ball so that ball doesn't release all
the way to the to the goalie so the
soccer code Cornell Soccer Coaches sort
of kicking it around seeing what that
check is like there's some moisture from
that snow left over did they like it
they actually liked it and that's
sometimes uh Fields will syringe for
really quick irrigation cycle before the
game to get a little bit of slip and
then it sort of checks at the end so
they were interested in that uh and then
very interested in the in the ground
passes the short passing Cornell as a
soccer team likes to to move the ball
around uh so they're playing a lot of
ground passes short passes trueness of
rolls that we talk about uh with with
golf putting greens right is it moving
left to right sort of snaking as it's
moving along the ground or is it going
in a straight line another version of
smoothness is the vertical aspect of
that the chatter so this is really
important for players these short passes
they want that ball to be on the ground
so they can handle it that first touch
is predictable if that ball is hopping
up and down maybe you got to settle it a
little bit that takes a little time and
you gotta uh it sort of slows the
process of this short passing so they
were interested in that
uh but overall what they were interested
Frank was the the playability the the
performance of the of the ball right how
that's going to affect how they play uh
I didn't hear anything about uh player
safety right and so one thing I was
interested in was like hey this is a
this is a cold field are we too firm so
I took the Clegg out there that morning
and thankfully we were in the the ideal
ranges so it wasn't uh excessively firm
the plague sort of how we think about
concussion risk or you know slip and
fall injury risk uh versus some of the
stuff you're doing John with you know
with the ball rebound that's maybe a
playability measure we have this ramp
that we roll it down basically a stint
meter for athletic fields that's sort of
an indication of the speed of the field
how it plays and then we've got these
other things that are measurable
measuring actual field safety stuff we
talk about on this show all the time the
sheer vein you know how much uh you know
what's the level of give you're gonna
have as an athlete uh sticking and
moving and then this cool I think your
lab is developing something here John
with a shoe that's planted on this Force
device that I think you're sticking into
the ground energy attenuation how that
is going to move back into the athlete
that seems like maybe a field safety
measurement so it's interesting for us
you know we talk about field safety all
the time and I think the athletes and
the coaches uh and John maybe this is
where you come in they're probably not
so worried about the field safety
they're worried about hey are we going
to win this game how is that ball gonna
react that's going to uh influence the
the outcome of the game that's that's
what I noticed when I was kicking a ball
around with them a little bit right yeah
well it's it's definitely you hope that
they don't think about the safety am I
going to be unsafe when I'm playing on
this field they want to focus on the
game and obviously winning and uh yeah I
love what you had and all the ball you
know right there you see the vertical
ball bounce and I and I had to post that
on Twitter because I had to show that
actually Dr Rogers and I do work
sometimes physically so
um but yeah we do that we do the ball
roll but one of the other things and I
need to send you a video of it I wish I
would have known that um we do uh angle
ball research because when you show
switching the field or putting that
through ball
um but you know when they wet the pitch
before a game and at halftime they want
that ball to skip they don't want it to
bounce up so when you're changing the
field dropping it back and crossing the
field that ball Landing in front of the
other player they don't want it bouncing
higher than basically their knee so they
could trap it
um so this is the rebound angle you're
talking about right yeah you don't throw
it in a very vertical you want sort of
right so we yeah so we do a lot of
research where we launch the ball in on
an angle we've got like a basically a
goalie treat trainer that sends it we
launch it in and we at the certain speed
I think it's 50 some kilometers an hour
that we put it in we know the angle the
velocity
then we can video capture the angle and
the velocity that comes out measure the
coefficient and restitution and how many
milliseconds it's in touch with the
surface for and we can control that and
we can say all right now for World Cup
you know you've got Miami at sea level
you've got Mexico City at 9 400 feet
and you've got you know Vancouver or
Seattle at sea level also but cool
season grasses versus warm season
grasses how do you manage these pitches
and then you got indoors at Sofi
how do you manage these pictures so that
the ball is going to be the same coming
off knowing that there's different
species different microclimates and
environments to do that so that's that's
the work we're looking at is what mowing
Heights of the cool season grasses
versus the warm season grass surface
moisture so that ball is going to be
consistent for if a team's playing in
Miami then going up to Toronto to play
so they're expecting
regardless of the venue
performance of those fields are going to
fall in an expected range right they
have a set of Standards not for the
angled stuff but they have a expect for
the ball bounce there's a certain
percentage that the ball has to come
back at and those are expectations we're
taking it to another level with our
testing is is doing some of the angled
stuff to really fine tune that
um because you know it was really easy
in Qatar for the most part they had the
furthest distance between the stadiums
was 43 miles and it's all they were all
over seated
um
that's palom yeah so you know rye grass
over seeded yeah overseeded with
perennial rye grass past palom
overseeded with so you could have
eight stadiums be the same now we've got
16 stadiums that we can't have the same
grass but we can so we're going to
narrow it down to a few grasses a couple
grasses blue rye and probably a Bermuda
and well I went mine in through the FIFA
stuff John and I'm sure you had some
play in this and again you know for
people listening that aren't involved at
the highest level of World Cup uh we're
gonna get to this but there's gonna be a
lot of sites across the country that are
going to host these soccer teams when
they come in right they're gonna they're
gonna have to you know there's gonna be
training grounds there's gonna be campus
grounds as well as these uh 16 locations
so obviously this program that fever
came out with and all of these
Publications are available uh on the
people website so again you know just
because you're not you know working at
these operations you still have access
to this information and some really good
stuff for our average Sports field
manager soccer field managers to keep uh
available where you should be testing
the number of tests you do this is
performance testing who can do it do you
need somebody to come in or can the
ground staff do it things like ball roll
rebound vertical depth deformation shock
absorb absorption surface evenness all
of this testing stuff should be readily
available uh to anybody that's
interested in it you know one of the
things John I'm so glad this has gotten
a lot of play at the sfma meetings every
year right because this is the kind of
thing that we need everybody doing not
not just the highest level why can't a
high school field uh be held to these
standards not just for safety and
performance because we have the
technology to do it oftentimes what
we're lacking is the expertise in the
grounds people and the support of the
grounds people even if they have the
expertise they might not have the
resources to do it now for those that
really want an inside Baseball look at
this uh this tiger Turf talk
groundskeeper chat that you had with
Trey and Jose was really good I listened
to it just the other night and
anticipation of this you know of course
I was around there right when this was
starting to happen at Michigan State
yeah right when you were a student and
you know we got the bid in Detroit and
then off I went to Wisconsin and you and
steyer and and Trey went on and did this
great work so if anybody wants more
information about this you certainly can
listen to it here now Trey's getting
some mileage out of this John yeah he is
they're building something at MSU you
know trace it you know if he's anything
he's a great promoter and he really
knows how to promote this I know
Michigan state has been all over this
and you guys are partnering between the
University of Tennessee and Michigan
Michigan State to support all of these
operations that are going on now there's
a lot of that's a lot of goofy
stuff that's going to start happening
when you're going to start growing grass
inside and then you have these Turf
guidelines that just got you know you
just did what I'm assuming this is a a
2.0 version these natural turf
guidelines and what was really
interesting and I think I get this
question all the time oh you know can
you how much wear and tear can natural
grass take compared to Synthetic Turf
right oh and you have all these fully
natural to these hybrid systems in a lot
of different ways that I gotta believe
is significantly enhancing
um the wear tolerance of these surfaces
and to your point all these in this
manual you sort of raided a the
different grass types for how they do
for the different characteristics
whether it's a desirable or an Optimum
condition and I think it was interesting
they must be a European thing smooth
stalked metal grass right that's what
they call Kentucky Bluegrass in Europe
you've got these eggshell drainage
systems that you're probably going to
wind up using under natural grass on
your synthetic Fields right is this
what's going to be under those fields
John yeah so this is a kind of a concept
because one of the things we're charged
with is in the dome stadiums you know we
don't want to lose sight Lines by
building up a conventional you know
12-inch pitch over four inches of gravel
because that takes out those Club level
seats or that front row of seats and
that's those are some money seats right
so we're looking at things like this
let's that looks like that's the Perma
void there yeah we're looking at is
their take out the artificial turf have
the concrete or asphalt floor in the
stadium put in that thin drainage layer
maybe a shock pad that you would put
between under an artificial turf we're
looking at that here right yeah and then
the grass on top right yeah and then so
we're going to have the real grass on
top that might be a hybrid carpet or a
hybrid stitched system that's gonna it's
only gonna be two and a half three
inches of grass
so you've been playing around with Trey
and Jackie Guevara right on yeah I saw
the PHD student yeah she's the PHD
student working on the kind of the
shallow pitch shot on plastic profile as
part of her component we got two grad
students at PhD students at Michigan
State and we've got two grad students
here at Tennessee more doing the light
stuff and getting ready to do the light
stuff so that's yeah that's right there
in Mexico City down there doing trials
in Mexico City setting up trials because
you know they have cucuya grass in their
stadium in Mexico City
you know that plays completely different
than the blue and the Bermuda so
but you know come to find out if you
look at the weather of Mexico City it
really never gets this may is the
hottest month and it's average
temperature 81.
it's 7 000 feet no nine thousand no over
nine thousand ninety five and so and it
still gets down to the 50s and low 60s
at night so perfect weather for
Bluegrass and rye grass and so we went
to uh their National training grounds
for the Mexican national soccer
Federation and they have rye grass there
they have a four-year-old ryegrass pitch
so we're looking at you know you can
we're going to look at growing Kentucky
Bluegrass and perennial ryegrass for the
Mexico City game so Ross is out there on
this plastic grown Bluegrass and he
tweeted this out with uh you know an
inch and a half thick on plastic now
listen you know and I know
I think Trey grew rye grass on plastic
in the 90s I know Marty Petrovic did
some sod on plastic here in the 80s this
isn't an entirely New Concept what are
your thoughts about sod on plastic for
the average school grounds or the
municipal grounds as a as patches as you
know you can produce it in what eight
weeks six weeks yeah so no no ideas no
it's a new idea right like you said it's
been around for a long time and that's
what my Master's was on was sod
production on plastic back in the 90s in
the mid 90s so
um when when I was uh like you said you
know I worked for John steyer who was
Trace technician at the time and John
steyer looked at me and another
undergrad and said you two need to go to
grad school so myself and Brian hargan
went on to grad school so because of
John steyer's advisement so yeah so one
of the things that came up in this uh in
this uh planning God not the the natural
Turf thing is resource planning and
procurement and I just put this picture
on because I don't even know what this
molar is but it looks like a really wide
rotary not a real mower so give me some
sense first off uh I'm curious about
these things and then I want to talk
about the broader project that you've
got you know where you've got to do
these other sites right there's going to
be a lot more sites what kind of mowers
are these and why not just use reels
they do use real mowers
um they're primary mowers that what FIFA
really likes to use are these what they
call pedestrian 34 inch wide pedestrian
reel mowers they also have ones that are
equal like that that I think that might
be that what they call the Hoover like a
vacuum yeah it's a rotary but that's for
post match where they go and they pick
up as much they're all about the debris
removal because if you think about
having a sand based root Zone with a
hybrid fiber and then the grass over top
you can't top dress that to dilute the
facts or or the organic matter that's
accumulated if you if clippings get down
or whatever so they've got to remove as
much of the debris to keep that organic
matter built up so in Europe you know
what they do is in England
the soccer season's getting ready to end
here in the next month
they'll come in in June and they'll
phrase Mo out all of the Rye graphs off
of those pitches add a little bit more
sand get that organic matter that's
accumulated that surface and reseed they
grow perennial rye grass as an annual
crop in all these premier league
stadiums so are those stadiums the
hybrid systems so when they phrase Mo
they they hit these fibers I'm assuming
that reduces their lifespan yes oh yes
yes it can for sure especially when
they're using the the metal phrase
mowers to cut them down and that's a
Desto grassmaster system I think pitcher
on the right so there's there's
different there's different ones and
there's different
you know there's CIS grass there's grass
Max other companies that do the same
stitching capabilities and they use you
know cork shoe shaped fibers bigger
bundles so they are more rigid and stay
up better so the Technology's Advanced
with that a lot
um we're doing a lot of management on
that a lot of mate like with warm season
grasses that have these fibers
it could actually get worse if you if
you have a Bermuda grass with a hybrid
Stitch system because what it does is it
makes that hearing point of that surface
it makes it a firmer surface but if the
stolens grow over it what we find is
when we traffic it it flips up like a
comb over in the wind so it you have to
manage these differently and so we're
actually brushing them like with an
aggressive power brush
um weekly and just breaking all those
stolens and so you're have trying to
make Bermuda grass like a bunch type
grass or only girl by rhizomes and to
stand straight up right and just stand
straight up and just to keep keep that
debris out and just keep it that profile
always never any thatch and just keeping
it always at that same height you know
I've I've heard of the system I believe
it's used in Asia called lay and play
and I'm sure you're you're familiar with
it
um it's a natural grass system that has
the fibers in it so here I have the
image from the FIFA document where
you've got a fully natural which is what
everybody's used to uh synthetic
elements I'm assuming this is beards old
work with zippers mixing those uh
reinforcements
and then the next one is oh the net lawn
is the second one the next one is the
stitched deso system
yeah so there's
yeah the synthetic element I think I'm
looking at the natural reinforced root
Zone you can have fibers that would be
like what bearded worked with or there's
just you know stabilizer Solutions or
something looks like the Easter grass or
whatever yeah you can just something to
stabilize the sand root Zone and that's
that's one thing that they look at then
there's the stitched where they actually
come in and Stitch
a product and there's so there's no
backing and then there's the carpeted
one which is basically like what you see
with our third generation artificial
turfs
um less density and hopefully a more
open backing but it's a carpeted system
that's filled with sand and then seeded
so so one of the things I'm fascinated
with as you're going to progress on this
in the next several years do you imagine
that what you're developing here will be
able to be made affordable to the
average Municipal School uh you know
Sports District where a sod grower you
know let's say let's go to this natural
synthetic carpet based stuff you know we
know Tony Leonard is doing this Primo
Turf but it's I don't think there's any
synthetics in that I think it's just
thick sod that's pop dressed on and they
cut it and lay it and then throw it out
can you imagine after you do Sofi for
example I'm assuming it's going to be
this last one this natural synthetic
carpet base that you're going to lay out
do you imagine it can be rolled up
brought back to the farm managed again
and then hauled somewhere else yeah
there's there's definitely the potential
for doing stuff like that
um you know the key is growing on
plastic and how much is it abused when
it's in the stadium or where its
application is used and we've been doing
this I've been the advisor for the
National Stadium in Singapore since
2017. and that's what we've done is they
they have we have three pitches that we
grow
outside on concrete and they're just and
they're zoysia grass pitches and they're
when it's time to have an event we just
go take one of them put it in the
stadium and and condition it a couple
weeks before the game play the games and
then just cut it back out and take it to
the nursery and we can swap pitches it's
it's it's helped save them almost two
million dollars a year in their
maintenance so here's my question for
you John
I know I know you a long time I'm PR I
know you're gonna pull this off what I'm
what I'm interested in is because I know
you also work with the NFL PA a little
bit when you pull this off in Sofi
what's going to stop the NFL from saying
well I mean there are I mean Pennington
is funding all this stuff now what's
going to stop the Players Association
from saying wait a minute you did it for
FIFA you did it for the World Cup you
can't do it for us for eight games a
year I mean I only play well in so far
they got two teams right so it might be
a little bit more
um how long do you think you can keep it
in there remember back in the silver
Dome days when it was closed in right
yeah I mean I think what did you get a
month out of it before it started to
fail what's your sense about the future
whether what you develop is going to be
standard in places that are demanding to
play on natural grass yeah well it all
comes down to events for these stadiums
they're not football stadiums they're
they're event centers right
um I think I think Nissan stadium with a
tiny things played made they make like
five or ten times more money off three
days of Taylor Swift than they do the
entire season of the Titans
so I guess
in the back because
these you know the stadium only gets a
little bit of rent from the football
team whereas they get part of the
tickets the concessions and the parking
from a concert or a truck and tractor
pull so is that why brabel was pissing
and moaning about natural grass and why
he wants Synthetic Turf in there I don't
know they've got Synthetic Turf so they
said it was to the injuries but that's
contrary to all the you know the what
the players so yeah always want grass
the players want grass and this is going
to show that you know it's gonna cost
money but you could have grass and how
long can you keep it in there it depends
what other events are in there that can
justify it but we're we're we've got
some really cool lighting that we're
doing research with and I can I've I
condemn and raise the the white light or
amber light
um different lights I can change the
blue and the red wavelength and I can I
can make it a short sturdy grass I can
make it grow faster and recover and we
come we're coming up and I got a PhD
student and I'm gonna try to bring on
another one because of light Light
Recipes too optimized yeah these things
and see we think we think yeah Bluegrass
needs 15 let's say 15 moles of light or
18 moles of light per day well if you
actually have 40 or 30 blue light do you
really need
18 moles can you get away with 12 moles
we don't know that yet and this is the
work we're trying to do right now it's
all right listen we're at 10 30 but I
can't let you go without some commentary
because I know you have the expertise
and everybody's got an opinion
um what was your sense of what happened
at the Super Bowl
um what happened at the Super Bowl was
uh will not happen again let's just
happen again the the app the it was and
it was not
um Andy Levy is the sports field manager
for the Cardinals and he didn't wasn't
able to inspect Assad that went in there
he wasn't able to manage it or be a have
a voice in it and as you know that's
wrong remember the silver Dome when you
put grass in the silver Dome or when you
put when they put graft inside that
Stadium they never ever have to water it
it doesn't it's transport they over
watered that like crazy
the individual that was in charge and
that person's not there anymore so
that's probably all that and I think and
I think we'll leave it at that but the
last comment on that is no one got hurt
and it probably didn't compromise the
outcome of the game
and if that was the field for the Super
Bowl the year before
obj might still be might not have missed
a season because he would have slipped
instead of stuff because he was it would
have been on grass not artificial so I'm
just I can't say it but his foot
probably would have given and that's
right
you know what I did notice is there was
a lot of people making Cuts not slipping
I think I wonder does Synthetic Turf
give them so much traction that they get
away with not planting their feet
properly and then they take that same
muscle memory onto a natural grass field
that might be a little slick on the
surface they don't plant their feet
right and they slip because I saw a lot
of guys jerking if they planted that
foot right it's stuck because I'm sure
your sheer vein showed it was okay yeah
well that yeah that'd be interesting I
wish we could have taken our Flex device
that you saw so because that can measure
the displacement of the surface and how
far a shoe goes through and the forces
that it takes and the time that it takes
because artificial turf it doesn't
it gives you a greater force over a
shorter distance and a quicker time so
it's a bigger jolt and a lot of times
you've got a different what they call
gait the angle and that's where maybe
that jolt that force that angle pops
your joints
guy I'm just a glass guy what a treat
right Carl what a treat
yeah this there's so many nuggets in
here today that I have to process all of
this too even even the angle rebound
stuff I remember I think Scott ebden and
Michelle DeCosta did that with tennis
courts a different brasses on tennis
courts too so yeah I'm gonna go back
here in Knoxville if you want to come uh
play on it there
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu